now we know that there's no way we're
going to be able to fit a tree to a
non-additive matrix by definition of
what a non-additive matrix is but maybe
we can construct a tree that is in a
sense the best approximate solution for
a given distance matrix for example
consider the non-additive distance
matrix that we encountered earlier in
the talk shown below along with the
following tree to measure how close this
tree is to the distance matrix we need
to compare the entries in D ie
upper case D with the distance between
the corresponding leaves in the tree ie
lowercase D the matrices are symmetric
so we only need to consider the entries
above the main diagonal of course now
for this example notice that the read
values disagree between the matrix and
the tree the distance from I to L for
example is 3 not 4 which is what the
tree indicates and the distance from J
to L is 5 not 4 which is what the tree
indicates so in general we can compute
how well a tree fits a distance matrix
by computing the sum of squared errors
between the distance matrix upper case D
and the distances between leaves in the
tree that we're given lower case D so to
denote this sum of squared errors we use
the term discrepancy of TD now for this
particular tree there are only two
nonzero errors both of which are equal
to 1 and so the discrepancy is equal to
2 however this is not the best we can do
for this tree why don't you take a
moment to see if you can find edge
weights that provide a smaller value of
discrepancy can you find maybe a
provably best assignment of edge weights
for this tree in general there is a
polynomial algorithm that will minimize
the sum of squared errors if we are
given the structure of the tree T in
advance but in practice we're not going
to know the structure of the tree in
advance so we'll need to minimize the
sum of squared errors Oh
for all possible tree structures the
number of tree structures is exponential
and the number of leaves in the tree and
so unfortunately this least-squares
distance based phylogeny problem is
np-complete and so it's not going to
help us fit a tree to a non-additive
matrix unfortunately